EARLY IN ON TIME THANK YOU. OUT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER FOURTH
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
BASE HERE BATES HERE MORNING
MORNING HERE ROTH ROUGH HERE
WILL PRESENT WILL CARE ATKINS
HERE. THANK YOU I THINK IF
POSSIBLE WE CAN GO AHEAD AND DO
THE BILL REFERRAL AS A CONSENT
ITEM ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES. MY BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING I ROUGH ROUGH I
WILL WRITE WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE THANK YOU. FIVE ZERO
ON IT LET ME GO AHEAD AND
INVITE MISTER DAVID KIM UP WE
HAVE ONE APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT IS OUR
SECRETARY OF THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. SO WELCOME. I IT'S A
GOOD FOR YOU. WE WILL ASK THE
IF YOU WANT TO AND I INTRODUCED
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
THAT IS SPECIAL TO YOU TODAY
AND THEM YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WELCOME GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
INTRODUCING A COUPLE MEMBERS OF
MY FAMILY WHO ARE HERE. MY WIFE
JULIE CAM AND MY MOTHER GRACE
CAM AND THEY'RE SITTING IN THE
FRONT ROW MY MOTHER LIVES IN
SEAL BEACH AND SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT BOTH OF THEM HAVE
BEEN HAVE LONG BEEN A SOURCE OF
INSPIRATION. STRENGTH
ENCOURAGEMENT AND LOVE. AND I'M
SO GRATEFUL THAT THEY CAN MAKE
IT HERE TODAY. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE BEFORE YOU TODAY. THIS IS A
PIVOTAL TIME FOR TRANSPORTATION
IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
TRANSPORTATION LANDSCAPE IS
UNDERGOING MASSIVE
TRANSFORMATION DUE TO
TECHNOLOGY AND NEW MOBILITY
OPTIONS. ON TOP OF THAT
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING FACTORS.
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IS
AGING AND INCREASING CONGESTION
AND LONG COMMUTES CONTINUE TO
BE A REALITY STATEWIDE. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. FATALITIES AND
SERIOUS INJURIES ON OUR
ROADWAYS ARE INCREASING. AND
FINALLY WITH CALIFORNIA BEING
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD COMES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MOVING
FREIGHT SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY
ALL MAINTAINING WHILE
MINIMIZING ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS ESPECIALLY ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SO
ALL OF THIS ADDS UP TO BIG
CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES. I WILL TACKLE
THESE ISSUES WITH A SENSE OF
URGENCY. AND ARE WILL APPLY THE
MANY EXPERIENCES AND LESSONS
LEARNED OVER MY THREE DECADES
IN FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AS WELL AS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO BRING ABOUT
BETTER MOBILITY OUTCOMES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. INNOVATION IS
A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR STRATEGY
TO EXPAND THE ABILITY FOR ALL
WHILE REDUCING TRANSPORTATION
RELATED FATALITIES. AND WITH
THE ERROR OF AUTONOMOUS AND
CONNECTED VEHICLES UNFOLDING WE
ARE CREATING A STATEWIDE POLICY
FRAMEWORK. TO PLAN FOR THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO MENTION THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN SP ONE ARE
BOOSTING THE ECONOMY BY
EMPLOYING THOUSANDS ACROSS THE
STATE AND HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES WORK ON IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. SB ONE
IS ALLOWING US TO BRING OUR
AGING TRANSPORTATION NETWORK TO
STATE OF GOOD REPAIR. ALONG
WITH IMPROVING TRANSIT SYSTEMS
AND TRADE AND COMMUTE CORRIDORS.
WE ARE KEEPING OUR PROMISE TO
DO THIS AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE. MODERNIZING THE DMV
IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
FOR ME. I'M WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DMV IS NEW LEADERSHIP
TEAM TO IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS ALL
BECOMING A MORE EFFICIENT
ORGANIZATION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES
BEFORE US ARE SIGNIFICANT. WE
ARE AT A CRITICAL MOMENT WERE
OUR COLLECTIVE ACTIONS AND
DECISIONS WILL SHAPE THE
ABILITY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
ACHIEVE A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE. TO FULLY MEET THEIR
MOBILITY NEEDS AND TO ENABLE
OUR CITIZENS TO THRIVE IN A
HEALTHY. SAFE AND PRODUCTIVE
MANNER. I PLEDGE TO BRING A
RELENTLESS FOCUS ON IMPROVING
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOR
THE BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE BEFORE
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR ROTH YOU
STARTED SO OFTEN. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM ACTUALLY I HAVE
NO QUESTIONS OF MISTER
SECRETARY WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU FOR AGREEING TO SERVE WHILE
WE DO NOT REALLY KNOW EACH
OTHER YOU KNOW FOLKS WHO I KNOW
AND I HAVE NOT I'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED AS A BONUS RULES
COMMITTEE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE APPROACHED ME. TO
EXPRESS NOT ONLY SUPPORT FOR
YOUR CONFIRMATION. BUT TO TALK
TO ME ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE
BACKGROUND. AND TRACK RECORD
THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
GOVERNMENT SERVICE OVER THE
YEARS SO CONGRATULATIONS I LOOK
FORWARD TO. MOVING YOUR
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK ONE THING AS
YOU CONTINUE TO SERVE. AS A
SECRETARY OR TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY AND THAT IS TO HELP US.
WATCH OVER THE ALLOCATION OF SB
ONE FUNDS AS WE PUSH THOSE
FUNDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
INSURE. THAT THE FUNDS ARE
PUSHED OUT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE HISTORICAL ALLOCATION
FORMULAS THAT MANY OF US RELIED
ON WHEN WE VOTED FOR THAT
MEASURE WHICH FOR SOME WAS A
VERY TOUGH VOTE. A YEAR SO AGO
SO AND I KNOW YOU WILL DO THAT
AND I KNOW YOU WILL DO A GREAT
JOB SO CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM. THANK
YOU CENTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM I AM VERY MUCH
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION AND
ARE PASSIVE CROSS ALONG THE WAY
WAY WAY BACK WELCOME BACK TO
CALIFORNIA WELCOME BACK HOME. I
WAS SATISFIED WITH ALL THE
ANSWERS YOU GAVE ME AND BUT
LIKE THE NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
AND IN MY OFFICE FOR MY
CONSTITUENCIES DMV SO MAYBE GO
A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO YOUR
VISION AND- WHAT THEIR MISSION
SHOULD BE MAYBE HOW TECHNOLOGY
CAN IMPROVE. SERVICES TRACKING
STATIONS WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
ELABORATE TERMS OF WHERE YOU
LIKE TO SEE THE AGENCY GO YOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER AND
I TOO ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION
THE OTHER DAY. WE ARE HEAVILY
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING THE DMV
ESPECIALLY CUSTOMER SERVICE
AND- IT IS OUR GOAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT TANGIBLE IMPROVEMENTS
ARE FELT AND SEEN ON THE GROUND
BY OUR CUSTOMERS. AND THAT
INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
CUSTOMER SERVICE TO IT
IMPROVEMENTS. AND WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED. WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT OF STEVE GORDON AS
THE G. THE NEW DMV DIRECTOR. HE
BRINGS WITH HIM AN IMPRESSIVE
BACKGROUND FROM SILICON VALLEY
HE IS A TECHNOLOGY. EXPERT AND
HE IS TAKING A GOOD HARD LOOK
AT THE I. T. SYSTEM. TO
STABILIZE AND THEN ULTIMATELY
MODERNIZE THE SYSTEM SO IT IS
OUR GOAL TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS SEE AND FEEL THOSE
X. THOSE IMPROVEMENTS ON THE
GROUND. AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
RIGHT APPRECIATE THAT AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU ON
MISTER KIM OF WE HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION WE SHARE MANY
THINGS INCLUDING AN OLD COLLEGE
I YELLED. FIVE OF. MISTER Q.
AND I BOTH WENT ON TO THEM SO
WE HAD SOME GOOD REMINISCES
ABOUT BETTER. HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION I ECHO THE SAME
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE OF
SENATOR ROTH REGARDING. OUR
YOUR BACKGROUND AND ON
DIFFERENT INCREDIBLE
APPOINTMENT SHE WOULD BRING SO
MUCH TO THE TABLE THAT'S NEEDED
DIAZ CERTAINLY WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. JUST A
COUPLE THINGS SO I'D LIKE YOU
TO BRING FORWARD. BECAUSE THEY
CAME UP IN OUR CONVERSATION
MOTOR VOTER I'M- COMFORTABLE
THAT MISTER GORDON WITH THIS
TECH BACKGROUND IS GOING TO
HELP WITHOUT. THE CHAIR A
LITTLE OF YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT
AND THEN ALSO BECAUSE THE A CH
P. ISSUE WITH SAND ON THE MASS
MEDIA. BEYOND ALL OVER US SHARE
A LITTLE BECAUSE YOU DID WITH
ME ABOUT. YOUR CONTROLS AND HOW
THAT IS NOT. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT IT GOING
FORWARD WITH WHAT YOU ALL HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO ON THAT FRONT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. WITH RESPECT TO MOTOR
VOTERLET ME ASSURE YOU THAT
THE DMV AND SECRETARY STATES
OFFICE ARE COORDINATING.
REGULARLY CLOSELY THERE'S A LOT
OF COLLABORATION PARTNERSHIP TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNICATION IS
ALWAYS AT THE FOREFRONT AND WE
ARE FULLY COMMITTED. TO
IMPLEMENTING MOTOR VOTER. AS
IT'S INTENDED. THOROUGHLY
ROBUSTLY AND ACCURATELY AND SO
I AM CONFIDENT WE GOT THE
SYSTEMS AND PROTOCOLS IN PLACE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE C. H. P.
ARE YOU REFERRING TO THE
OVERTIME ISSUE OR SOME OTHER
SHALL OKAY. RIGHT UP THERE. I
AM IN TOUCH ON A REGULAR BASIS
WITH COMMISSIONER STANLEY WE
HAVE TALKED TO THE EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT THE SITUATION IN EAST LA.
I'VE BEEN BRIEFED ON THE
SITUATION WITH RESPECT TO THE
OVERTIME. ABUSE IN EAST LA AND
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THAT IS. A
SITUATION THAT IS CONFINED TO
THE HE'S STILL A- STATION DOES
NOT EXISTE WIDE CONTRARY TO
WHAT HAS BEEN REPORTED AND THEN
SO THAT. WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THIS IS LIMITED TO TWO ONE AREA
STATE. THANK YOU MR CAM AND I'M
VERY COMFORTABLE AFTER A
DISCUSSION THAT THAT IN FACT IS
THE CASE SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CONGRATULATIONS I HARDLY
SUPPORT YOUR CONFIRMATION. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
ISSUES. WITH MOBILITY AND MY
DISTRICTS SO IT'LL BE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP AND YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THE TRAFFIC LADY A LOT.
THANK YOU CENTER. SENATOR MONEY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SECRETARY KIM LET ME ALSO OFFER
MY CONGRATULATIONS AND ADD TO
THAT THE THINKING YOU FOR YOUR
YEARS OF SERVICE BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL AND YOU MENTION
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOUR FAMILY FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND FOR THEIR
SUPPORT I KNOW THE ANSWER. TEAM
EFFORTS. THAT COMMITMENT THAT
YOU'VE MADE TO SERVE OUR STATE.
I ALSO ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION
AND SOME. COMMON CONNECTIONS
ALONG THE WAY IS YOU KNOW MY
DISTRICT INCLUDES HIGHWAY ONE
WHICH IS KIND OF AN ON GOING
PROJECT FOR PROTECTING SAFETY
IN. THAT VITAL THOROUGHFARE FOR
NOT JUST TOURISM BUT ALSO WORK
FORCE. WE TALKED SOME ABOUT AS
WE GET MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT
WITH THEIR VEHICLES MORE PEOPLE
MOVING TO ZERO MISSIONAL
LECTURED VEHICLES. HOW DO WE
SUSTAIN SUPPORT FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE I KNOW SB ONE.
WAS OVERDUE IN IS BEING
DIRECTED TO A TARGET PRIMARILY
FIRST AND FOREMOST SAFETY
REPAIRS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
HAD WE MEET THE CHALLENGE OF
MAINTAINING THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH MORE FUEL EFFICIENT
VEHICLES. AND HAD WE MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR OUR OUR
NEEDS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR YOU BIãU POINTED IT
QUICKLY POINT OUT THE CONUNDRUM
WITH RESPECT TO THE CURRENT GAS
TAX BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH THE RISE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND GREATER
FUEL EFFICIENCY. THE CHALLENGE
IS HOW DO YOU MAINTAIN THAT
REVENUE BASE AND I THINK WHAT
EVERYBODY CAN AGREE ON AMONG
TRANSPORTATION STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN
WASHINGTON. IS THAT IN THE LONG
RUN THE GAS TAX IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE AS A LONG TERM
REVENUE SOURCE AND WE HAVE TO
START LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVE
SOURCES OF REVENUE AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT THE ROACH CHARGE
SYSTEM. WHICH WAS PILOTED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA A COUPLE YEARS
AGO IS A POTENTIAL STRATEGY
MOVING FORWARD. WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IN THIS ROLE IS CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE THAT FURTHER AS YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA. LAUNCH THE
LARGEST PILOT PROGRAM A COUPLE
YEARS AGO LARGEST IN THE NATION
MUCH WAS LEARNED WE STILL HAVE
MUCH MORE TO LEARN MORE
RESEARCH NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
SO I WANT TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS IN THE CTC. ANOTHER
INSTANT PARTIES TO SEE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
A POTENTIAL ROAD CHARGE SYSTEM
A BECAUSE THAT'S A THAT THAT IS
A HUGE CHANGE IN DYNAMIC IF WE
ARE EVER TO GO TO THAT. SYSTEM
OF COLLECTING REVENUE FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. BECAUSE AGAIN YOUR POINT
IS WELL WELL TAKEN THE GAS TAX
IS NOT SUSTAINABLE THE LONG
TERM WE HAVE TO START LOOKING
AT OTHER ALTERNATIVES. CREATE
WILL THANK YOU AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS IN I THINK I
SPEAK FOR ALL OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE WANT TO SUPPORT
YOU IN BEING SUCCESSFUL. YOUR
SUCCESS WILL BE THAT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN A BE GLAD TO
MOVE ON THE NATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OR DID. DO ALL
IT OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CAM THANK YOU AND
IT JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK
THINGS ONE I DIDN'T HAVE THE
LUXURY TO GET IT A SIT DOWN
WITH YOU BEFORE TODAY BUT LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE I
THINK WE GOT PLENTY OF OUR OUR
COMMENTS FROM FOLKS WHO REALLY
SUPPORT THIS. NOMINATION SO I
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
I'VE HEARD I WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE NEXT DAY OR
SO IF YOU ARE HERE TO GET THE
CHANCE TO SIT DOWN THIS IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC I
AND I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS
OUR APPOINTMENT IS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
OF FIVE IF WE COULD DO THAT SO
TO COMBAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND- I WOULD SAY. REPRESENTING
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY BEEN THERE I
HAVE HEARD I AND I FOR MY STAFF
AS WELL AS PEOPLE IN THE AREA
SO THANK YOU THE BORDER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. LEADS ME MEN AS
WELL AS ALL THE OTHER
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY A STEPPED INTO
ALL OF THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION WITH
YOU ABOUT YOUR VISION SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT YES THANK YOU WITH
THAT ARE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC. I WILL SAY
A COUPLE OF THINGS. TO YOUR MOM
AND YOUR SPOUSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT DAY. AND ORDINARILY
WE GET TO ENJOY IT A LITTLE
MORE. BUT MY COLLEAGUES AND I
START SESSION AT TEN AM AND WE
HAVE EXECUTIVE SESSION AS WELL.
SO I HOPE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR ALL THE GREAT ACCOLADES
FOR YOUR HUSBAND AND YOUR SON.
I AT YOU IN AND AROUND AND
DURING OUR CONFIRMATION ON THE
FLOOR IN THE NEXT WEEK I FOR MR
CAM. AND THAT IS TO LET THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC KNOW WHEN
I SEE PEOPLE WHO'VE TRAVELED
FROM AFAR TO BE HERE TODAY. AND
ORDINARILY WE GET TO ENJOY A
LONGER SESSION BUT I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU. I'M GONNA TAKE THE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT FIRST I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO GIVE ME
YOUR NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND ONLY YOUR POSITION. AND
THEN AS YOU STEP INTO THE
HALLWAY YOU CAN HAVE A
WONDERFUL CONVERSATION. I ALSO
DON'T LIKE NOT BEING ABLE TO DO
AN EXTENDED VERSION
PARTICULARLY WHEN SOMEONE AS
IMPORTANT. AS THE SECRETARY IN
THIS POSITION IS TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND TO ALL OF
YOU. BUT IN THE INTEREST OF
EXECUTIVE SESSION AND FLOOR I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO HONOR THAT
AS I START WITH THOSE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU'LL COME FORWARD.
I DID. YOU SEE THAT IS A LOVELY
SITE THAT IS A GOOD SIGN. SO
AND WELCOME IT'S GOOD TO SEE
SOMEONE FROM SAN DIEGO THANK
YOU THANK YOU HASSAN ACROSS
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT IF OF SAN
DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND I SENT A LETTER
YOU SHOULD HAVE IT. IS AN
AMAZING MAN I KNOWN HIM FOR
TWENTY YEARS ARE FIGHTING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE YES SIR FIVE MILLION TO A
COMMISSION MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS COMMON I
JUST SAY I'M THE EXACT DIRECTOR
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS GAG.
WE ALSO TURN THE LETTER ON
BEHALF OF SECTOR CAM AND WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT HE IS
ONE OF US BECAUSE HE ACTUALLY
GREW UP IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'D REALLY SUPPORT THIS
NOMINATION. THANK YOU. YES SIR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
BASEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE IMPERIAL COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION PENSION. PROUD
TO. HONOR OF DAVID KIM IN THIS
POSITION AS HE IS VERY WELL
AWARE AT YOU SAID ABOUT BORDER
ISSUES AND ACROSS OUR- OUR OUR
OUR LAN PORTS OF ENTRY AND WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH DAVID
ACROSS OUR STATE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S YVONNE
GARCIA I AM PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
THE BUTTE COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS UP IN CHICO. I'M
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE NOR
STATE SUPER REGION COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S NORTHERN SIXTEEN.
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCIES A LETTER WAS
SUBMITTED HERE TO SUPPORT.
DAVID KIM THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I'M SURE MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH THEIR AND RE
DISSOCIATES FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WAS IN HE WAS LABOR
STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR KEEFE
DONE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
SELF HELP COUNTY COALITION
TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES TO MAKE UP
THE SALES TAX TO HELP SUPPORT
OUR INSTRUCTIONS STRAIGHT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR EDDIE BERNACCHI MAP IT TO
CLIENTS THE UNITED CONTRACTORS
AND THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMATED
FRACTURES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR MORE
THAN ONE MAN CHUCKLES CORN
BEHALF FOR SEVERAL
TRANSPORTATION ENTITIES
COUNCILS GOVERNMENTS FOR SAN
LUIS OBISPO SANTA BARBARA
STANISLAUS TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES FOR MONTEREY MORAN.
AND CEMETERY SO. SHE THE
GOVERNOR MAKE AN INSPIRED
CHOICE WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
THE SECRETARY US AND WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT AND
CALTRAIN CONNECTING SAN
FRANCISCO SAN MATEO. AND SANTA
CLARENCE THE NOMINATION THANK
YOU. HI GEORGE AGAIN DORMAN AT
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MORE
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING TO MANY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN BENITO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
THE VENTURA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MATT ROBINSON WITH THE
SAN MATTEO CITY COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS THE
SOLANO TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIP IN
AUTHORITY WHICH REPRESENTS ALL
OF THE OCEAN GOING CARRIERS. IN
SUPPORT OF A CONFIRMATIONTHANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT SECRETARY KIM HAS
EXPERIENCE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND THAT HE'S ALREADY REACHED
OUT TO LOCAL AGENCIES. THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL IS SO IMPORTANT ON
TRANSPORTATION. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I TELAMON SING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES PLACE TO WONDERFUL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MEN CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING ENTRANCE
WE WAS CHAU YOUR ANSWER HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY OTHERWISE ANALYST
METROLINK OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY METRO
THE FRESNO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY OF IN
SUPPORT OF THE SECRETARY'S
NOMINATION TODAY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARTELLA TORY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CORPORATE
REGIONAL COUNCIL AND WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TANK
YOU'RE GONNA BE HELPFUL TO GET
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
OTHER CANDIDATES OCCUR IN TERMS
OF APPOINTMENT ALSO CONCUR WITH
THE CENTER ROSS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ALLOCATION OF THE SB ONE
FUNDS. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TIM CHIANG WITH THE AUTO CLUB
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN FULL
SUPPORT OF MR KIM'S NOMINATION
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING HAPPY
ALMOST END OF SESSION EXUBERANT
ALTES WITH THE TRIPLE A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR ALEX TORE IS ON BEHALF OF
THE ELEGY INK HEADQUARTERED AND
MANUFACTURING IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND INTELLECTUAL
TECHNOLOGY INC ON STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KERR BLACK UNVEILS
WILSON ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION AND THE WESTERN
STATES TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU YOU FORGOT SOMEONE. TWO
KIND OF IT WAS TO. THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES AND THE LOS ANGELES
WORLD AIRPORTS AUTHORITY WITH
THE SUPPORT YEAH THOSE ARE BIG.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. IN OPPOSITION. OKAY I
MR CAM IT DOESN'T GET MUCH
BETTER THAN THAT TRUST US AND
I'M SURE YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH
MANY OF THESE SIMILAR THING SO
YOU KNOW WITH THEIR EYES WHICH
OF MY SENATORS WOULD LIKE TO.
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES AYE BATES AYE
MINING MINING I ROUGH ROUGH I
WILL ALL RIGHT WILK AYE ATKINS
AYE. IT IS UNANIMOUS
CONGRATULATIONS SOME OF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY WE
WILL GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.
HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY